- [Female Voiceover] Many
people know the sound of vinyl,
but it's how it's made that's
a whole different story.
- [Ton Voiceover] The
record industry offers
a one-stop-shop for all our customers,
so we do the cuts in-house
on both lacquer and DMM.
We produce our own coppers.
We do the print of all
the sleeves, labels,
so the customer doesn't
have to go to other printers
or cutting rooms to get
all their stuff together.
We do everything in-house.
(upbeat music)
(bell chimes)
- [Female Voiceover] This
is Ton, the proud owner
of Record Industry, one of the largest
vinyl pressing plants in the world.
Located in Haarlem in the Netherlands,
Ton has had a lifelong love of vinyl.
- I started this, my music
career, as being a DJ
in a local club, private radio stations
playing, uh, the old disco
dance grooves in the '80s.
- [Female Voiceover] The
factory opened in 1958
and in recent years has
seen a surge in sales.
- Last year, we did nine and a half million,
and this year we're aiming for 10,500,000,
maybe 11,000,000.
(upbeat music)
We press for all the major companies
being Sony Music, Universal, Warner Music,
and a lot of local smaller labels.
My wife and me try to run Record Industry
as being a family company.
We don't have children ourselves,
but in the end we're
always making a bit fun
of it and we say we
have 100 children here.
I like the vinyl.
I like the size of the format,
nice pictures, you know?
You can say you can be
proud of this product.
If you look at a CD, for instance,
it's not something you're cherishing,
a record you cherish.
The music was more some kind of a hobby,
so I could turn my hobby
into a real profession
running this beautiful plant.
(upbeat music)
(bell chimes)